these are supporters of Christina
Fernandez the kirschner who came to the
federal court building in Buenos Aires
to protest against Argentina's judiciary
Kushner was sentenced to six years in
prison and given a lifetime ban on
holding public office after being found
guilty of corruption it's the first time
an Argentinian vice president has been
convicted of a crime whilst in office
Kushner is a victim of political
persecution
what they want to do is get her out of
politics in a good way or a bad way they
fail to kill her and now they have this
option
three months ago Kushner was the target
of an assassination attempt when a man
pulled the trigger off his handgun
inches from her face as she greeted
supporters the gun failed to fire
on Tuesday a panel of three judges found
Kushner guilty of aggravated fraud
Christina Elizabeth Fernandez is
sentenced to six years imprisonment life
disqualification from holding public
office legal accessories and the cost of
the proceedings because she is
criminally responsible for the offense
of fraudland administration to the
detriment of the public
[Applause]
is accused of directing millions of
dollars of Public Works contracts to a
family friend
prosecutors say they have found dozens
of irregularities in public works
contracts in the province of Santa Cruz
where the Kershner family originally
comes from
the former president denies all charges
accusing the tribunal in charge of a
political Witch Hunt and serving the
interests of the opposition
this is much simpler it's not law fair
it's not a Judiciary party it's not a
parallel State and Mafia it's a Judicial
Mafia Christina Fernandez the Kershner
was Argentina's president for eight
years between 2007 and 2015. she is now
this country's vice president she's a
divisive figure in this country while
there are many who continue to support
her there are many others who would like
to see her in prison
foreign
ER is expected to appeal against the
Court's decision despite her conviction
she has Congressional immunity and is
unlikely to head to jail anytime soon